let me talk to you about parallelism
in your post titled reasoning about
async IO semaphore you talk about a fast
food restaurant Silicon Valley that has
only one table is this a real thing I
just wanted to ask you about that is
that just like a metaphor you're using
or is that an actual restaurant in
Silicon Valley it was it was a metaphor
of course okay
I can imagine such a restaurant so for
people who don't then read the thing you
should you should but it was uh
idea of a restaurant where there's only
one table and you show up one at a time
and you're prepared and actually looked
it up and there is restaurants like this
throughout the world
and it just seems like a fascinating
idea you stand in line you show up
there's one table
they um they ask you all kinds of
questions they cook just for you that's
fascinating it sounds like you'd find
places like that in Tokyo it sounds like
a very Japanese thing or in the Bay Area
there are Papa places that probably more
or less work like that I've never eaten
at such a place the fascinating thing is
you propose is the fast food this is all
for a burger it was one of my rare sort
of more literary or poetic moments where
I thought I'll I'll just open with a
crazy example to catch your attention
and the rest is very dry stuff about uh
locks and semaphores and how uh
semaphore is a generalization of the
lock well it was very poetic and well
delivered and it actually made me wonder
if it's real or not because you don't
make that explicit and it feels like it
could be true and in fact I wouldn't be
surprised if somebody like listens to
this and knows exactly a restaurant like
this in Silicon Valley anyway can we
step back and can you just talk about
parallelism concurrency threading
asynchronous all these different terms
what is it sort of a high philosophical
level the the fisherman is back in the
boat well the idea is if the fisherman
has uh two fishing rods
uh since fishing is mostly a matter of
waiting for a fish to nibble well it
depends on how you do it actually but if
you had two if if you're doing the style
of fishing where you sort of you you
throw it out and then you let it sit for
a while until maybe you see a nibble one
fisherman can easily run two or three or
four
fishing rods and so as long as you can
afford the equipment you can catch four
times as many fish by
a small investment in four fishing rods
and so since your time you sort of say
you have all Saturday to go fishing if
you can catch four times as much fish
you have a much higher productivity and
that's actually I think how deep sea
fishing is done you could just have a
rod and you put in a hole so you could
have many rods uh what is there an
interesting difference between
parallelism and concurrency
and asynchronous is there one subset of
the other to you like how do you think
about these terms in the computer World
there is a big difference when people
are talking about parallelism uh like a
parallel computer
that's usually really
several complete CPUs that are sort of
tied together and and
share something like memory or an i o
bus
uh concurrency can be a much more
abstract concept
where
you have the illusion that things happen
simultaneously but what the computer
actually does is
it spends a little time running some
this program for a while and then it
spends some time running that program
for a while and then spending some time
for the third program for a while
so parallelism is the reality and
concurrency is part reality part
illusion yeah parallelism typically
implies that there is multiple copies of
the hardware
you write that implementing
synchronization Primitives is hard in
that blog post and you talk about locks
and semaphores why is it hard to
implement synchronization Primitives
because at the conscious level our
brains are not trained to to sort of
keep track of multiple things at the
same time like obviously you can walk
and chew gum at the same time
because they're both activities that
require only a little bit of your
conscious
activity but try balancing your
checkbook
and watching a murder mystery on TV yeah
you'll mix up the digits or you'll miss
an essential clue on in the TV show so
why does it matter that the programmer
the human
is uh is bad because the programmer is
at least with the current state of the
art is responsible for
writing the code correctly and it's hard
enough
to keep track of a recipe that you just
execute one step at a time
chop the carrots then peel the potatoes
mix the icing you need your whole brain
when you're when you're reading a piece
of code what what is going on okay we're
we're loading the number of mermaids in
variable a and the number of mermen in
variable B and now we take the average
or whatever
metaphor to Metaphor I like it you have
to keep in your head what is an a what
is in B what is in C uh hopefully you
have better names
and that is challenging enough
if you have two different
pieces of code that are are sort of
being executed
simultaneously weather is using the
parallel or the concurrent
approach
if like
a is the number of fishermen and B is
the number of programmers
but in another part of the code a is the
number of mermaids and B is the number
of merman
and somehow that's the same variable if
you do it sequentially if first you do
your mermaid mer people computation and
then you do your people in the boat
computation it doesn't matter that the
variables are called A and B and that is
literally the same variable because you
you're done with one use of that
variable but when you mix them together
suddenly
the number of more people replaces the
number of fishermen and your computation
goes dramatically wrong and there's all
kinds of ordering
of operations that could result in the
assignment of those variables and so you
have to anticipate all possible
orderings and you think you're smart and
you'll put a lock around it and in
practice in terms of bugs per lineup per
a thousand lines of code
this is an area where everything is
worse so a lock is a mechanism by which
you forbid only one
Chef can access the oven at a time
something like that and then semaphores
allow you to do what multiple ovens
that's not the bad idea because if
you're sort of
if you're preparing if you're baking
cakes and you have multiple people all
baking cakes but there's only one oven
yeah then maybe you can tell that the
oven is in use but maybe it's preheating
uh and so you have to maybe maybe you
make a sign that says oven and use
uh and you flip the sign over and it
says often is free when you're done
baking your cake
uh that's a lock that's sort of and and
what do you do when you have two ovens
or maybe you have ten ovens do you you
can put a separate sign on each oven or
maybe you can sort of someone who comes
in wants to see at a glance
and maybe there's an electronic sign
that says uh there are still five ovens
available
uh or maybe they're already
three people waiting for an oven so you
can
if you see an oven that's not in use
it's already reserved for someone else
who got in line first
and that's sort of what what the
restaurant metaphor was trying to
explain yeah and so you're now tasks
you're sitting as a designer of python
with a team of brilliant core developers
I have to try to figure out to what
degree can any of these ideas be
integrated and not so maybe this is a
good time to ask what is async IO
and how has it evolved since Python 3.4
wow yeah so we had this really old
library for for doing things
concurrently especially things that had
to do with IO and uh networking i o was
especially a sort of a popular topic
and
in the python standard Library we had a
brief period where there was lots of
development and I think it was late 90s
maybe early 2000s and like
two little modules were added that were
the state of the Art of Doing
asynchronous IO or sort of non-blocking
AIO which means that you can keep
multiple network connections open and
sort of service them all in parallel
like a typical web server does so iOS
input and outputs you're writing either
to the network network connection or
reading and writing to a hard drive to
storage also possible and you can do uh
the ideas you could do to multiple while
also doing computation
also running some code that does some
fancy stuff yeah like when you're
writing a web server when a request
comes in a user sort of needs to see a
particular web page
uh you have to find that page maybe in
the database and format it properly and
send it back to the client and
there's a lot of waiting waiting for the
database waiting for the network and so
you can handle hundreds or thousands or
millions of requests
concurrently on one machine anyway waste
of doing that in Python were kind of
stagnated and uh
I forget it might have been around
2012 2014
uh when someone for the umpteenth time
actually said these async chat and async
core modules that you have in the
standard Library are not quite enough to
solve my particular problem
can we add one tiny little feature and
everybody said no that stuff is not to
but you're not supposed to use that
stuff write your own using uh
third-party library and then everybody
started a debate about what the right
third-party library was
and somehow I I felt that
that was actually a cue for well maybe
we need a better state of the art
module in the standard library for for
multiplexing input output from different
sources you could say that it spiraled
out of control a little bit it was at
the time it was the largest python
enhancement proposal that was ever
proposed
and you were deeply involved with that
at the time I was very much involved
with that I was like the lead architect
uh I ended up
talking to people who had already
developed Syria's third-party libraries
that did similar things and sort of
taking ideas from them and
getting their feedback on my design and
eventually we put it in the standard
library and after a few years I got
distracted I think the thing the big
thing that distracted me was actually
type annotations
but other people kept it alive and
kicking and it's been quite successful
actually yeah
in the world of python web clients so
initially what are some of the design
challenges there in that debate for the
pep and what are some things that got
rejected what are some things that got
accepted to stand out to you
there are a couple of different ways you
can handle parallel i o and this happens
sort of at an architectural level in
operating systems as well like Windows
prefers to do it one-way and Unix
prefers to do it the other way
you sort of
you have an object that represents a
network endpoint say a connection with a
web browser that your client
and say you're you're waiting for an
incoming request two fundamental
approaches are
okay I'm waiting for an incoming request
I'm doing something else come wake me up
or of course sort of come tell me when
uh something interesting happened like a
packet came in on that network
connection
and the other Paradigm is we're on a
team of a whole bunch of people with
maybe a little mind and we we can only
manage one web connection at a time so
I'm just sitting
looking at this this web connection and
I'm just blocked until something comes
in and then uh I'm already waiting for
it
uh I get I get the data I process the
data and then I go back to the top and
say no sort of I'm waiting for the next
packet those are about the two paradigms
one is
a paradigm where there is sort of
notionally a threat of control whether
it's an actual operating system thread
or more an abstraction in async IO we
call them tasks
but a task in AC and KO or a thread in
other contexts is devoted to one thing
and it has Logic for all the stages like
when it's a web request like
first wait wait for the first line of
the web request parse it because then
you know if it's a get or a post or a
put or whatever or an error then wait
until you have a bunch of lines until
there's a blank line then parse that as
headers and then interpret that and then
wait for the rest of the data to come in
if there is any more that you request
expect that sort of standard web stuff
and the other thing is and there's
always endless debate about which
approach is more efficient than which
approach is more error prone
where I just have a whole bunch of
stacks in front of me and uh whenever
a packet comes in I sort of look at the
number of the pack that there's some
number on the packet and I say oh that
packet goes on this pile
and then I can do a little bit and then
sort of that pile provides my context
and as soon as I'm done with with the
processing I sort of
I can forget everything about what's
going on because the next packet will
come in from some random other client
and it's that pile or this pile
uh and every time a pile is maybe empty
or full or whatever the criteria is I
can toss it away or use it for a new
space but
several traditional third-party
libraries for asynchronous i o
processing in Python shows the model of
a callback
and that's that's the idea where you
have a bunch of different stacks of
paper in front of you and every time
someone gives you a piece gives you a
new sheet you decide which stack it
belongs to
and that leads to a certain style of
spaghetti code that I find sort of
aesthetically
not pleasing and I I was sort of never
very successful and I had heard many
stories about people who were also
sort of complaining about that style of
coding
it was very prevalent in JavaScript at
the time at least because it was like
how the JavaScript event Loop basically
works and so I thought well the
task-based model where each task has a
bunch of logic
we had mechanisms in the Python language
that we could easily reuse for for that
and I thought I want to build a whole
library for asynchronous networking i o
uh and all the other things that may
need to be done asynchronously
uh based on that Paradigm and so I just
chose a paradigm and tried to see how
far I could get with that and it turns
out that it's pretty good paradigm so
people enjoy that kind of Paradigm
programming for asynchronous Io relative
to callbacks
okay beautiful so how does that all
interplay with
the infamous Gill the goal the global
interpreter lock
maybe can you say what the Gill is and
how does it dance beautifully with a
sinkayo
the global interpreter lock
solves the problem that python
originally was not written with either
asynchronous or or parallelism in mind
at all there was no concurrency in the
language there was no parallelism there
were no threads
only a small number of years into
Python's initial development
all the new cool operating systems like
uh Sun OS and silicon graphics irex and
then eventually posix and windows all
came with threading libraries
that lets you do multiple things in
parallel and there is a certain
certain sort of principle which is the
operating system handles the threads for
you
and the program can pretend that there
are as many CPUs as as there are threads
in the program
uh and those CPUs were completely
independently
and if you don't have enough CPUs the
operating system sort of simulates those
extra CPUs on the other hand if you have
enough CPUs you can get a lot of work
done by deploying those multiple CPUs
but python wasn't written
to to do that
uh and so
as libraries for for multi-threading
were added to C
but every operating system then there
was adding their own version of that
we thought and maybe we were wrong but
at the time we thought well we quickly
want to be able to support these
multiple threads
because they seemed at the time in the
early 90s when they were new at least to
me
they seemed a cool interesting
programming Paradigm and one of the
things that that python at least at the
time
felt was nice about the language was
that we could give a
safe version of all kinds of cool new
operating system toys to the python
programmer like I remember
one or two years before threading I I
had spent some time adding networking
sockets
uh to Python and they were very literal
translation of the networking sockets
that were in the BSD operating system so
Unix BSD
but the nice thing was if you're using
sockets from python then all the things
you can do wrong with sockets in C would
automatically give you a clear error
message instead of just ending up with a
malfunctioning hanging program
and so we thought well we'll do the same
thing with threading
but we didn't really want to rewrite The
Interpreter
to be thread safe because that that was
was like
that would be a very complex refactoring
of all The Interpreter code and all the
runtime code because all the objects
were written with the assumption that
there is only one thread and so we said
okay well we'll take our losses we'll
provide something that looks like
threads
and as long as you only have a single
CPU on your computer which most
computers at the time did
uh it feels just like threads because
the the whole idea of of multiple
threads in the OS was that even if your
your computer only had one CPU you could
still fire up at many threads as you
wanted well within reason maybe 10 or 12
not 5000.
uh and so we thought we had conquered
the
the abstraction of threads pretty well
because multi core uh CPUs were were not
in in most python programmers hands
anyway
and then of course a couple of more
iterations of Moore's Law and computers
getting faster and at some point
uh the chip designers decided that they
couldn't make the CPUs faster but they
could still make them smaller and so
they could put multiple CPUs on one chip
and suddenly there was all this pressure
about
do things in parallel and that's where
the the solution we had in Python didn't
work
and that's that's sort of the moment
that the guild became
became infamous
because the guilt the guilt was the
solution we used to sort of
take this single interpreter and share
it between all the different operating
system threats that you could create and
so as long as the the hardware
physically only had one CPU that was all
fine
and then as Hardware vendors were
suddenly telling us all oh you got to
paralyze everything's got to be
paralyzed
people started saying oh uh but we can
use multiple threads in Python and uh
then they discovered oh but actually all
threads run on a single single core yeah
I mean is there a way is there ideas for
in the future to remove
the global interpreter log Gill like
maybe multiple sub interpreters some
tricky
interpreters on top of interpreters kind
of thing yeah there there are a couple
of possible uh Futures there the the
most likely future is that we'll get
multiple sub interpreters
which each run a completely independent
Python program nice uh but they're
they're still some benefit of
of sort of faster communication between
those programs but it's also managing
for you this running a multiple python
programs yeah so it's hidden from you
right the it's it's hidden from you but
you have to spend more time
communicating between those programs
because the sort of
the attractive
thing about the multi-threaded model is
that the threads can share objects at
the same time that's also the downfall
of the multi-threaded programming model
because when you do share objects
you were and you didn't necessarily
intend to share them or uh there were
aspects of those objects that
that were not reusable you get all kinds
of concurrency bugs and so
the reason I wrote that little blog post
about semaphores was that concurrency
bugs are just harder it would be nice if
python had uh no Global interpreter lock
and it had the so-called free threading
but it would also cause a lot more
software bugs
uh the interesting thing is that there
is still a possible future where we are
actually going to or where we could
experiment at least with that
because there is a guy working for
Facebook who has developed a fork of C
python
that he called the no-gill
interpreter where he removed the Gill
and made a whole bunch of optimizations
so that the the single threaded case
doesn't run too much slower
uh and multi-threaded case will actually
uh use all the cores that you have
and so that that would be an interesting
possibility
if we would be willing as a python core
developers to actually
uh maintain that code indefinitely
and if we're willing to put up with the
additional complexity of The Interpreter
and the additional sort of overhead for
the single threaded case and I'm
personally not convinced
that
there are enough people
uh needing the speed of multiple threads
with their python programs
that it's worth to sort of
take that performance hit and that
complexity hit
and I I feel that the Gill actually is
pretty nice
Goldilocks point between no threads and
uh all threads all the time but not
everybody agrees on that so that is
definitely a possible future the sub
interpreters look like a fairly safe bet
for 312 so say a year from now